morning John it is not morning obviously
it is nighttime it is London and I have
been having a fantastic time as such I
am faced with the brutal conundrum of
what I should be discussing in this
video gonna be the powerfully packed
humanity of the London tuber the silly
tranquility of Brighton Beach or the
sherwood forest meets rich suburb of
Hampstead he actually those things
pretty easy to cross off the list when
it comes down to it the two things that
I knew I needed to do while I was here
in the United Kingdom and the two things
that in fact have blown my mind more
than I even thought they would one the
Natural History Museum which gathered
and I got up early so we could be first
in line to go into and yes the Harry
Potter studio tour in Watford science
versus Harry Potter
that's my brain I this is an easy choice
for most people probably even seems like
it tooks to position maybe choosing
between opposites but not for me let's
sort it out let's sort it out with some
superlative let's start with the saddest
day at the studio tour there was Albus
Dumbledore's office and a mannequin
wearing his robes and that made me sad
but that's not gonna make me near as sad
is like the last skeleton of a dodo
which that's a whole species gone man
creepiest thing hands down no question
the living breathing Voldemort doll
thing I'm it's maybe the worst thing
I've seen in my entire life
most inspirational yes the massive
amounts of time and money and energy
that went into creating every bit of the
Harry Potter universe in perfect detail
that is inspiring but not nearly as
inspirational as being in the presence
of Darwin's pigeons Wallace's collection
pressings that were used by Linnaeus
himself contextualizing myself within
the broader history of life on this
planet and feeling a direct connection
to the people who teased out those
truths best architecture the Natural
History Museum is an amazing example of
German Romanesque architecture to voc's
the sacredness of the natural world in a
very human way and it does that very
successfully and every nook and cranny
there's some other little hidden thing
evoking science and nature and it is
absolutely beautiful but Hogwarts wins
because Hogwarts JK Rowling versus
Charles Darwin
both slaved away for decades over
masterful works yes but Darwin's care
and independence and fortitude
definitely puts him on top also he had
severe digestive problems which I can
sympathize with vast community all
science is collaborative it is always
part of a community Darwin is certainly
no exception but Harry Potter 2 is a
collaborative work Joe Rowling's world
has benefited from the contributions of
a great number of people whether you're
talking about screen writers and actors
or are you talking about the community
of people who have sprung up around it
to love it together unintended
collaborators like myself and Harry and
the Potters in Melissa and Ally and
Starkey I think the fact that most art
projects are not this collaborative and
this so clearly in so many ways to me at
least a makes this another one for Harry
Potter which brings us to a tie so yes I
have failed to decide which thing I'm
gonna make my video about today but it
turns out that it was able to be pretty
good like choosing between your children
or more correctly in my case it's like
choosing between my parents these are
two things that didn't just contribute
to how I understand the world they built
me as a person oddly enough what I love
about science is that enthusiastic
perpetual drive toward objective truth
and understanding what I love about
Harry Potter is that an ironic drive
toward objective goodness loyalty and
love and building together something
greater than ourselves and something
better than ourselves not just for
ourselves but for everyone those are two
things that are really like guiding
principles of my life and so no I'm not
gonna pick between them and yes I am
excited to be able to talk about them
here on a bench in Tower Hill in London
John I'll see you on Tuesday